[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN LAWYER:
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome very much to the
inaugural talk about the AI
Hub.
We're very excited on behalf
of the AI platform team
to share what we've been
working on over the last year.
Really quickly, some
housekeeping items.
For those of you who have
not used the Dory application
for questions, please feel free
to enter your questions there
and vote on questions.
We have a lot to
demo today, so I
don't know that we're
going to have time
at the end of the presentation
to answer questions,
you know, face to face.
But we will be--
[INAUDIBLE] and Lily here
will be answering questions
in real time during the
show, as well as afterwards,
we'll continue to add the
answers to the Dory app.
So really quickly,
the AI platform team
has been very, very
focused on trying
to solve real world
machine learning
problems for our customers.
And as we've been
talking to customers
over and over and over again,
we hear three main concerns
every single time.
The first one is, people
have trouble managing
infrastructure.
Whenever you're talking
about machine learning,
you've got GPUs TPUs, CPUs.
You have to do
distributed training.
It's kind of a
nightmare sometimes,
and some people would
rather not do it.
Some people just can't.
In addition, the
real world is hybrid.
There's stuff on Cloud,
there's stuff on prem.
Anytime you have one
of those boundaries,
it gets to be a little
bit of a nightmare trying
to move workloads
from one to the other.
That's a problem that
we want to solve.
The second problem we hear is
really about a talent problem.
There's just not enough
talent to go around.
You've got a data
scientist, you've
got production
engineers that are
used to putting those machine
learning jobs into production.
There's just not enough.
So we need to figure out
how to create 10 times force
multipliers for those teams,
so they can do 10 times
more projects and really enable
and empower your organizations.
To do that, we need
collaboration tools that
actually focus on reuse and
collaboration across teams,
and essentially create
a center of excellence
within your organizations
to meet your needs.
That's the theme you're going
to hear over and over again
in this talk.
The third problem that we keep
hearing is, people are having
a tough time getting started.
And the reason is
because machine learning
is a very large
area of learning,
and so some people
are new to cloud.
Some people are new
to machine learning.
Some people are new to specific
techniques within machine
learning or to putting
those jobs into production.
Each one of those has a
different learning front
and so the question
is, how do each of us
gets started more quickly?
So how does Cloud AI help?
We have a number of new
products we're launching today,
including the AI Hub, along
with our new managed notebooks,
and we're going to demo
a number of these today,
as well as our Kubeflow Fairing
system, which we'll also
demo as well.
Really quickly, one of
the things to remember
is AI is really a team sport.
If you've ever seen
an organization put
a machine learning
model into production,
it usually takes a database
expert, the actual subject
matter expert, the
data scientist,
somebody from the
production engineering
teams to actually get
this to all work together.
So you really need to make sure
they're all working together.
So if we think about
this, each person
has a role to do in a company.
That role or that person might
have a different skill set.
They need different tools
to be able to do their job.
So the question is, how do we
make each one of these roles,
each one of these
people, successful
using machine
learning in the way
that they need to,
to do their job?
So really quickly, to
make sure we're all
talking on the same
page, let's talk really
quickly about the Cloud
Machine Learning stack.
At the base level, at
the foundation level,
we all are building on
infrastructure, right?
So whether it's compute
or storage or processing
elements-- could be
on prem or on GCP,
does not really matter--
that's the basic legal block
that you're working with.
Above that, GCP has a
number of managed services
to make your lives easier,
whether it's spinning up
a virtual machine to get
your Jupyter notebooks going,
or to do training or serving.
Those are services to
make it easier for you
to manage your infrastructure.
Or, if you choose to manage
your own infrastructure,
we can make creating the
Kubernetes clusters easier
with GKE.
Most data scientists
actually spend their life
above that stack, more on
the tooling and SDK level.
So we're talking
about the notebooks,
we're talking about
Kubeflow Pipelines
for orchestrating workloads.
And Kubeflow Fairing
is a new service,
which we'll demonstrate
a little bit later today,
which enables you to take
the same training code
and run it locally on your VM.
Or, with a small amount
of configuration change,
to make that run in a
distributed fashion on machine
learning infrastructure
on Google,
where we spin up the
machines, you do the job,
and then we'll tear it
down for you automatically.
Or you can end up having it
run on any Kubernetes cluster
that you choose, whether
it's on prem or a GCP,
in a true hybrid fashion.
And at the top of the
stack is the AI Hub.
What the AI Hub really is is
a collaboration tool where
you can find, then use,
and then share any AI asset
that you guys need
to do your job.
Obviously, Google is providing
some of those assets to share.
Some of our partners
will be sharing as well.
But it's also a place for you
to put your own assets that
don't get shared
with anybody except
within your organization.
That way, you can actually
start to share and collaborate
across the teams and
have these teams actually
go much, much faster.
So instead of having 12
different teams doing OCR
very differently, you get one
team doing OCR very, very well,
and each of the other
11 then configuring it
for your clients.
[COUGH] Excuse me.
So, really briefly,
one of the patterns
that you're going
to see is, we want
the AI Hub to be a
center of excellence
so that for every single
one of your people,
we want a familiar
pattern of discovering
what you want to do,
the tech, the asset
to actually help you do that.
Then you go use it.
When you actually get
something trained or working,
then you can share that
back with your team.
That could be a model,
that could be a notebook,
or that could be a pipeline.
And we'll see this later
on in the demonstration.
So today, the demonstrations
that we're going to be giving
will be focused on these
three personas, or users.
First of all, the
app developer who
is trying to put some
intelligence into their app,
how do they do that easily?
It will be about the
data scientist who's
trying to create a new training
algorithm using a notebook,
using different
assets from the Hub,
and then once they've
got it trained,
sharing it back with their team.
Or the ML engineer,
now that they've
got a pipeline, how do they
configure that pipeline,
how do they then deploy
it, how do they monitor it?
So first of all, let's talk
about building the smart apps.
So I'm going to be jumping in
and out of the presentation,
so just to warn you.
So the first thing
that we've done
is we've put all of Cloud
AI APIs into the Hub,
so they're really easy to find.
So you can see right
here that they're
highlighted as services.
So you can see all of
the different APIs here.
So let's say, for example,
I'm building a smart app
and I get users to
submit photos to me.
I might need to understand
what the heck that photo
is, whether it's a cat, or
a car, or is there something
that's maybe not
family safe in it.
So I can click on
the Vision API here.
I can quickly visit the
Products page for that product.
And I might need to change
the resolution, here.
And there's a demo right here
that you'll do really quickly.
So we can click on that.
And I've got a photo right
here that a friend gave me.
And I have to say
that I'm not a robot.
And off it goes.
And so it is actually
done bounding boxes
on a couple of people in the
photo that it's identified.
If you look at labels, it's
identified it correctly
as a baseball park.
If you look at the
Web Entities, it's
actually identified this
as the Oracle Park here,
just down the street.
So it's correctly,
actually, identified
the location of this photo.
And if you go to
the Safe Search,
you can tell that it's
fine to share publicly.
So that's actually
really, really valuable
if you're an app
developer and you just
need to consume some
of these services.
In addition, there are times
when you, as a developer,
might have data that's labeled.
But you don't know necessarily
a whole lot about machine
learning, and you
might need to customize
that model for your case.
Let's say you're a
manufacturer, you know.
The Vision API is going
to be able to tell
the difference between
tables and benches and screws
and bolts, but it might not
be able to identify all 10,000
parts on your warehouse lines.
So in order to do that,
you would supply the images
from your repos, and
you'd go to AutoML.
And here's the AutoML
Vision right here,
it's a beta service.
And from here, it then walks
you through the process
of giving the data,
identifying the problems
and the labels you're
trying to solve,
and puts it in your own project.
And then it will find the
right machine learning
model for your problem,
and optimize that model,
and then give it back to you.
As a developer, you
don't have to know
what's going on inside it.
You've just given it all the
parameters to do your job,
and it's actually
quite simple to use.
So the next journey
we're going to talk about
is, now, as a data scientist.
Now as a data scientist,
like we mentioned
before, one of the
big problems we find
is it's often hard to get
started on a new problem.
You might be an
expert in one thing,
and then your boss gives you
another problem to work on,
and you have to go figure
out how to do that.
So we have a number of great
notebook samples in the Hub.
And so right here,
I've identified--
these are all the notebooks.
And so maybe I want to--
this is a fun one.
Let's say I want to
do style transfers.
So I can look for
style transfers,
and here's an audio
style transfer,
here's a 3D style transfer.
This one's kind of fun.
So basically I can take a 3D
asset, you give it a texture,
and then it applies that
texture to that 3D asset.
So you can imagine, in gaming
or entertainment areas,
this might be something
that's interesting.
And you see this quite a bit.
And you can go off and
kick that off in a notebook
and go mess with the code and
change it, and share it back
with your teammates.
Or, let's see.
Maybe instead you want to do--
you've got structure
data, and maybe it's
in BigQuery or
something like that.
And you want to be able to do
a gradient boost to a decision
tree, so you'll
be using XGBoost.
Well, right here,
you have a pipeline.
Or, if we wanted to
restrict it to notebooks,
you can Restrict Notebook.
And here's an example of
how to use XGBoost using
Kubeflow Fairing, which
is that service we're
going to demonstrate
a little bit later,
that shows you how to
train it and then deploy
that on different locations.
So, just so you can
see how it works,
here is the notebook right here.
I can click Open in GCP.
We now have a new
managed service
so that we automatically spin
up a Jupyter Notebook for you,
on a VM, on GCP, to
make that easier.
So no more DevOps need
to go manage that.
You can either create it in a
new VM or use an existing one.
For speed, I'm just going
to use an existing one.
I can click Continue.
It spins up.
I've been using this demo VM.
And so here it is.
And so you can go ahead and
run that, if you'd like.
And so what you can see here
is all the standard code
to be able to read your
inputs, et cetera, OK?
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
So another thing
that the Hub does
is, it has added in a bunch
of great support for transfer
learning.
Now, one of the
critical problems
we hear about over and over
again is about a lack of data.
So if you're trying to do an
image classification model,
for instance, you may not
have millions of images,
but you might have
100 or 200 or 1,000
for your particular problem.
Well, how do you
solve this problem?
The technique of
transfer learning
is a way that you can use
an open source pre trained
model, that has been trained
on a general data set,
to learn the general features.
And then you can then
switch over to your data set
and fine tune it on your
data to really quickly train
on your problem.
And so we have a
number of these here,
and so you can see in the Hub--
how do I do that?
Well, let's go to the
TensorFlow modules.
And so here's a bunch
of different ones.
And let's say I want
Image Classification.
And so here's the Inception V3
embedding, here's mobile NAT,
a little bit later
on down is ResNet.
So let's say we want ResNet.
So here's one of the classic
embeddings right here.
So you can see
the original paper
where it was published in 2015.
So you can go learn about it.
Down here is the
code that you can
copy and paste to put
into your notebook,
to make that really easy from
a boilerplate perspective.
Or, the TensorFlow team
has made it really easy
to copy and paste with a URL.
So basically what you do
is you go click that URL.
And now, to make it
simple, I'm going
to jump to a notebook
that's already
got the boilerplate
in it, so you
can see how that's used, OK?
So right here, let's assume
that I'm a cancer researcher
and I might have some images
of cancer cells and non cancer
cells, and I want
to be able to tell
the difference between these.
And I want to use that ResNet
50 embedding that I just saw.
Well, I can look at
this notebook here,
and I do the common
updates of my libraries,
and set up my environment, and
convert the images to TFRecord,
so it works better with
TensorFlow, all standard stuff.
I can visualize some of
these images really quickly,
just to make sure that
I've done it properly.
I then set up my model.
And you can see, right here,
that's the URL of the embedding
that you just copied and pasted.
The rest of that code around
it is the boilerplate code
that the TensorFlow
team has provided
for you to just use that.
And then what you do is you
wrap that in a one layer Caris
network.
So it's got one output for
binary, cancer or not cancer,
and you'll basically
be ingesting
that embedding from
the TensorFlow module
and refining that model
using your data that you've
supplied to it.
It's really, really
simple to do.
And then, basically,
here's what you do to it.
It's wrapped in a Python
class, you go ahead
and go Train on it in that VM.
Or, now, if you're
using Kubeflow Fairing,
all you have to do is provide
a few parameters about,
where is your Docker registry,
where is your GCP project,
and give it the
base Docker image.
And then, with Fairing, you
specify the GKE back end on GCP
where you want to go run
it, and then submit the job.
And it goes and runs it on your
GKE cluster as it's set up.
Or, instead of
running it on GKE,
you may choose to use
the AI factory training
service, which used to be called
MLEngine up until this morning.
And with that service, we
set up the cluster for you.
We distribute that, we take
care of all the infrastructure.
It goes and trains.
When it's done, we tear
it down and you only
use for the services
that you use.
So that's a great way to do it.
We also have demonstrations of
how to use prediction from it.
So think now that you
are a data scientist,
and you're actually training
in a hybrid environment.
You're training on your
VM, wherever you are.
You're training on Cloud,
either in a managed
or an unmanaged situation.
Or, if you want, you can
create configurations
for running those
on any cluster you
want, on prem or any other
hybrid Cloud that you might.
OK, so now that I've
got my model trained
and I've got my
notebook working,
I want to share
that with my team.
So we provided, directly in
the service, the publication
capability so you can
share it with your team.
This Publish button is not
to publish to the world,
it's to publish within
your work group.
And you have Quick Ways, so
you can see all the assets
that you've created.
And these filters down here--
if I can get rid of that,
oops, that doesn't do it.
There it goes away.
I'm going to jump
straight to the apps
so I can show you
how to do this live.
If I click on this
Publish, you can
choose to share a pipeline,
which we'll talk about later--
Sasha will show us
that-- a trained
model of just the weight
files, or the notebook itself.
I'm going to demonstrate
the notebook.
So let's say that if this
is the Cancer Demo Notebook.
And from a data
type, this is Image.
So I'm setting up the
metadata to make it easier
to find for members
of your team.
And this is a training workflow.
Maybe it's a transfer learning,
from a labeling perspective.
And from a summary,
this is "use ResNet 50
to train an image classification
model for cancer detection."
There you go.
Click Next.
I can now upload a file.
And I've got this file
right here on my desktop.
I open it, I click Next.
It can now preview it.
And then I click Publish.
And if I don't get that
error, then it basically
shares to the rest
of your work group.
And they can start using it.
So with that, I'd like
to turn the time over
to Venky Rao, who's one of the
AI principles of Accenture.
And he's going to talk
about this experience
within the Accenture workflow.
VENKY RAO: Thanks, Justin.
Venky Rao from Accenture, I
work in Applied Intelligence
Organization with Accenture.
At Applied Intelligence, you
know, we help our clients
drive new business outcomes
using analytics automation
and AI.
We have a large team
of data scientists,
over 3,000 data scientists
across the globe.
And we also bring in a
foundation of data services
that are pretty unique
to the industry.
We have relationships with
over 200 data providers
and we also have curated data
sets in various industries
that's pretty unique to us.
And then we have
strategy consultants
who are deep experts
in various industries.
Together, it's all
these capabilities,
that's how we drive new business
outcomes for our clients.
Now when it comes to AI
Hub, we are super excited,
because with the size and
complexity of the Applied
Intelligence team at
Accenture, we are constantly
looking for new tools
that will help our data
scientists collaborate and, you
know, speed up our projects,
and improve efficiency,
and all of that.
So when we saw AI Hub, it
really fit into the needs
of our organization.
And I'm going to show
you how we are using it.
So one of the things, you
know, I forgot to mention was,
you know, in data
science there are
a lot of repeatable
processes and there
are a lot of steps that you
could share from one project
to the other.
And a lot of times, you
come in with your data set
and you have a hypothesis and
you want to experiment faster.
A lot of times,
we find teams kind
of doing the same thing
over and over again.
And with AI Hub, if
there's a nice catalog
that they can look up
and include those assets
into their projects and
build pipelines quickly,
that's a big win for us.
And that's what we
see with AI Hub, also.
So I'm going to show you--
While Justin showed
you how AI Hub looks,
the public view of AI
Hub, as a customer,
how does it look for you.
So this is a public
view that Justin showed.
And this is the restricted
view, which is Accenture's view.
This is where we have
published a few of our assets
within Applied Intelligence.
We have literally
hundreds of notebooks
that can be useful
for our project teams.
There are pre trained models
and various other assets.
And that's how we surface them,
you know, here within AI Hub.
And you can see
that the icon there,
and it shows that this
is a restricted thing,
and it's only available
for our organization,
because you have to be careful.
And you can't even
actually publish this
to the public view, anyways.
Let's say now I'm interested
in this particular notebook.
See, this is a great example
of a shareable asset.
One thing that we encourage
our data scientists
is to, when they get a
new data set, to make sure
that they apply some of the
responsible AI principles
that we encourage.
In this particular
case, let's say
I'm interested in understanding
how my data distribution is.
Instead of writing all of
that tooling once again, I
could easily look at this
and, as Justin showed,
I can actually bring this
up within a VM instance.
So I can select this, and yeah,
I've already opened one here.
So you can see that this
is a nice notebook for data
scientists to quickly
take a look at it,
then run it, and then
start changing it,
and then making it useful
for their own use case.
So we find this
extremely useful.
It's all one click, you know,
deployment of these notebooks,
and it really speeds
up the whole process.
So we are super
excited about this.
JUSTIN LAWYER: So I
hope you can start
to see the power of
being able to put
best practices in your own
private section of the Hub
to share within
your organization
and get everybody aligned
on best practices,
whether it's for fairness,
or recommendations, or fraud
detection, or whatever it might
be that your organization cares
about.
Now within Google, we do
something similar as well.
And so, for instance, these
TF modules that we use,
we use those millions
of times a day
on all sorts of products
throughout Google.
For the notebooks, we share
those best practices as well.
And with pipelines, we
have introduced a concept
to do industrial Google grade
pipelines, both in and out
of Google.
And Sasha will come up
and talk about this.
And while he's coming,
really quickly--
one of the complaints
that customers often
talk to us about us
is, why the heck is it
so much work to get a machine
learning model into production?
I created this model
in three weeks.
10 months later, I'm still
fighting with my DevOps team
to actually get it going.
Well, the reason is
because there's so
many pieces of the process
around the model weights
that actually are really
critical to make sure it works.
You need to make sure
that your data streams
that are coming in, in
production, are actually
the same distributions and
not distorted from what
you trained the data on.
You need to make
sure that you've
got the infrastructure right.
You need to make sure
you've got enough RAM,
so that things don't die.
You need to be able to scale
up to handle any arbitrary
volumes you've got.
You need to be able to
do A/B testing, to make
sure that any time
that you make a change,
that you're canarying
it and making sure
that something doesn't break.
There's a whole lot that
goes into making sure
that this actually works
and you don't get disasters
on your hands, right?
Well, the TFX team
created ways to understand
each step of pipelines, and
the Kubeflow pipelines team
created a way to
orchestrate these workflows.
And so Sasha will now come
up and talk about that.
SASHA SOBRAN: Thanks, Justin.
I'm Sasha Sobran.
I'm an engineer, a
machine learning engineer,
on the AI Hub team.
And I'm going to talk about
how AI Hub can jumpstart
your Kubeflow pipelines.
So what is Kubeflow Pipelines?
Kubeflow Pipelines is a
container orchestration
framework for production
end to end machine learning.
It comes with a
rich UI that you can
use to interact with Kubeflow
Pipelines, as well as a Python
SDK for more
programmatic execution.
It covers the full machine
learning lifecycle from data
all the way to serving
your trained model.
So let's say I'm a
machine learning engineer
at my company, OK, and I have
all our data in BigQuery.
And I want to take
that data, and I want
to use it for machine learning.
One of the best models to use
for tabular data is XGBoost.
And it's usually a good starting
point for a lot of engineers.
The next step I want to take
is, after training that model,
I want to deploy it to
AI Platform Prediction
so then I can make an
API available to the rest
of my team.
So let's talk about how
the content that we've
created for AI Hub can
fit into that use case.
All right, so first we have
ready to go pipeline templates,
OK.
These are full end
to end pipelines
that you can just bring your
data, fill the parameters,
and deploy them.
Next, we have example pipelines.
And so these are our reference
pipelines that give you
a good idea of what, kind
of, the best practices
for machine learning are.
And then we have
broken down components.
So each pipeline is composed
of multiple components.
And we've created this
suite of components
at multiple steps of the
machine learning lifecycle.
This includes preprocessing
for your ETL jobs,
training for any
out of the box model
you want to use that you
don't feel like coding up.
Or, if you have your own
in-house and proprietary models
in your favorite machine
learning library,
then you can use our
distributed frameworks
that work out of the box.
You just provide your model.
Next is the push to production.
OK, so once we actually create
that machine learning artifact,
we want to put it in a
place that it can be used.
So going back to that use case
of, I'm going from BigQuery
and I want to use
XGBoost, and then I
want to deploy to production.
So let's see how AI Hub
can help me do that.
I will click out to AI Hub, OK.
I've already set the filters
here for public assets,
so we're only looking at
what's publicly available.
Next, I've also set the
filter for Kubeflow pipelines,
so this will show me Kubeflow
pipelines and components.
And I said I wanted to
run an XGBoost trainer.
So let's search that.
OK, so right away, we
can see that we already
have a good amount of content
with relation to XGBoost, OK.
We have an XGBoost
trainer in Spark.
We have an XGBoost trainer
that takes advantage of GPUs.
And it's also distributed.
All of that is handled
under the covers.
So the first asset that came up
was training an XGBoost model
using data from BigQuery.
So let me go check that out.
In our documentation, we kind
of give you a quick overview
of what a component does.
So you can quickly figure out
if you actually need to use this
or not.
So here, we can see it selects
training and validation
data sets from BigQuery.
Awesome.
It trains an XGBoost
model, just what I wanted.
And then it will
deploy that model
to AI Platform Prediction.
So let's go ahead
and use this model.
We simply go up here and
download the pipeline.
And then let's jump to Kubeflow.
So this is Kubeflow.
It runs on Kubernetes.
It can run on any
Kubernetes engine
that you like,
OK, including GKE.
And this one was deployed
using the one click Deploy
feature of Kubeflow.
You just go to our UI
and you click Deploy,
and you have a Kubeflow
up and running.
So pipelines is a
part of Kubeflow.
Just selected it on the left.
And this is the initial
dashboard into pipelines,
and it shows you
all your pipelines.
We've already seeded a few
in here that you can see.
And let's go ahead and add that
pipeline I just downloaded.
So I'm going to pick a pipeline.
And then let's go ahead and
rename this to "BQ to XGBoost."
All right.
Go down and Upload.
So this will add this
pipeline to my deployment.
Now I can go click on it--
and I'll hide this here--
all right.
And I'm going to zoom out,
just so you can kind of get
a view of the full pipeline.
So this is a four step pipeline.
It grabs your BigQueries
for both your training,
your validation here and here.
It will then use that data.
It pipes that data into our
XGBoost distributed trainer,
and then deploys that model.
So one thing to know here
is that this pipeline
was completely composed by
all our individual components,
which are also
available on AI Hub.
So if you like any
of these components,
you can take them out and use
them in your own pipeline.
So, to run this pipeline,
I just hit Create Run.
I give it a name, OK,
and then I go down.
And I fill in parameters, OK.
And so this is very
straightforward
and will get you
running very fast.
Now, in the interest
of time, I went ahead
and ran this
pipeline earlier, OK,
and so let's go take a
look at the output of that.
So Experiments is
the place you go
to, to see where all
your runs have occurred.
Now, an experiment is a
logical grouping of runs.
So let's say that you have
a production pipeline.
You run it at some
type of schedule.
This is a place that you
can group those together,
to see kind of how
your production
system is changing over time.
So for this
particular experiment,
I've only run this one pipeline
as a demonstration, OK.
And I can click on it.
And now I can see that my
pipeline successfully executed.
Each of these check
marks comes in.
And I can go and look at the
logs for each of my steps,
look at my evaluation errors
as they're logged out.
And finally, I can actually
get my model endpoint
in AI Platform Prediction.
So let's take a step back
and go back to AI Hub.
OK, so let's say I don't
want to use XGBoost,
and I actually do a lot
of my work in TensorFlow.
One of the big frameworks that
Google recently fully open
sourced is TFX, which
is TensorFlow extended.
It's basically a production
machine learning pipeline,
tailor made for TensorFlow.
It's Google grade,
and that means
that it runs a majority of
the machine learning pipelines
inside of Google as well.
And now you can take
advantage of it.
The value add here is that
AI Hub, we host a reference
pipeline for you to look at.
You can also use that
reference pipeline
to then see how your
workflows should change.
So let's check that out.
So here's TFX.
And the first
thing that comes up
is this TFMA taxi cab
classification example.
So let's click on
that and take a look.
So this reference
pipeline, it uses
TFX for the use case of trying
to predict whether or not
someone will tip a taxi cab.
So let's say I'm interested
in using this pipeline
as a reference pipeline.
I can download it.
Let's go back to the Kubeflow
UI and go to Pipelines.
And I just simply upload
the pipeline again.
So, one thing to
know here is that I
don't have to use the UI.
I can use the
Python SDK if I want
more programmatic
execution and entry point
into Kubeflow pipelines.
So let's take a look
at this pipeline.
And so this one's a little bit
more complex than the last one
we saw.
And it has many steps,
including a validation
of data step, preprocessing,
training, and then
a model analysis step,
a batch prediction step
for a final evaluation, and
then a deployment step out
to AI Platform Prediction.
So again, to respect
your time, we've
run multiple runs
of this pipeline.
So let's see how we can use
Kubeflow Pipelines to analyze
those runs.
So let's go back to
the Experiments page.
All right, so we have
this taxi experiment here.
And I've said earlier that
this is a logical grouping
of pipeline runs, OK.
And right away,
you can kind of see
that there's a
lot of information
here that you can use
to compare these runs.
So the first thing to
know is that, again,
let's say that I'm
in production, OK,
and all my runs are succeeding.
My fourth run, OK,
did not succeed.
I see that right away
as a Failed status, OK,
and I can just click on that.
And I can see that my
data validation failed.
So I can click into
this, look at the logs,
troubleshoot, fix, and then
run the pipeline again.
Now one of my favorite
features of Kubeflow Pipelines
is the ability to
aggregate these runs
and then view them
all in one dashboard.
So let's take a look at that.
So first, I'm going to select
my runs that have all succeeded.
And then I'm going to go up
here and select Compare Runs.
OK, so this is a run
comparison dashboard,
and let's see what it tells us.
So first, it gives us
things like the duration
of the pipeline, OK.
It also gives us a quick
overview of these high level
machine learning metrics
that we may be interested in,
including accuracy and ROC.
And we can kind of see
that Run Three marginally
performed better
than the other runs
here, based on accuracy and ROC.
So let's go down
and see why that is.
So this also captures
the parameters
that you entered
into your pipeline.
So it's easy for you to
see the difference here.
So the only variation
between these three runs
was the hidden layer size.
And like we said, Run
Three was the best.
And we can see that the smallest
hidden layer size actually
performed marginally better.
So these are important insights
that you can pull out just
off this quick view.
Let's go down a little bit.
So next-- and I also love
this-- is Tensorboard.
OK, so for those who of
you who are not familiar,
Tensorboard is a powerful
tool for TensorFlow.
It allows you to deep
dive into your model
so that you can see its
performance as it trains,
as well as any other type of
metrics you're trying to track.
Now generally, to
use Tensorboard,
you have to write all your
models to the same directory
and kind of manage
that if you want
to get everything together.
Now what Kubeflow
Pipelines does is
it's able to aggregate
all these together,
all these runs together,
into the same Tensorboard,
so then you can easily
make comparisons at once.
And that's what
we're doing here,
under this aggregated
view of Tensorboard.
So let's open that up.
So here is Tensorboard.
It's already running.
This works out of
the box when you
deploy Kubeflow and
Kubeflow Pipelines,
you don't need to set it up.
And let's go down here.
And let's say I want to look at
my loss curves for all my runs.
That is super simple.
It's written here, and I can
go ahead and look, run by run,
what the loss curves were.
It also has everything else
you expect from Tensorboard,
including your graphs
distributions and so forth.
Now let's go back to
Kubeflow, and let's go down.
We can see there's some
other visualizations that
are also very beneficial,
confusion matrix,
for this problem.
And then the last thing that
I kind of want to highlight on
is that TFMA is also available
through Kubeflow Pipelines.
And so what is TFMA?
So TFMA is a part of TFX.
it stands for TensorFlow
Model Analysis.
So let's break that open.
So, again, Kubeflow
Pipelines is a rich UI
and it lets you pop out
to the TFMA Visualization.
So TFMA let you view
your model's performance
at different cross
sections of your data.
So then you can pinpoint
where your model is not
performing very well.
And then you can iterate
and improve that model.
This is extremely
powerful as you're
trying to find the best
model for your use case.
So here, we can kind of see
everything it gives back to us.
The trip start hours
was split up by time,
and we can see how
well it performed
at each hour of the day.
So let's close that.
There are a few more
features down at the bottom.
I'm just going to
gloss over them.
It shows you the ROC
curve right away.
And then these tables actually
give you a view into your data
that was used to train your
model, as well, for each
of your runs, OK.
Now let's go back to AI Hub.
And so I hope, in
summary, that you kind of
saw how powerful AI Hub
and Kubeflow pipelines can
be when they work together.
We have a lot of components
and pipelines already up
and available for you on AI
Hub that you can use today.
So please take a chance
to check that out,
and I'll hand it back to Justin.
JUSTIN LAWYER: Thank
you very much, Sasha.
[APPLAUSE]
So hopefully, by
now, you've been
able to see how impactful
sharing and finding
assets within the Hub
can be, whether that's
your APIs that you're wanting
to use within a smart app,
or whether it's
sample notebooks to be
able to learn how to do new
techniques from a notebook
setting, as a data scientist,
or from a production
experimentation framework, to
be able to do end to end machine
learning pipelines in a
scalable industrial fashion,
and to really understand how
to iterate on those pipelines
and to debug them.
It's a really fantastic tool,
all starting with the Hub.
So hopefully you can see that.
But we don't want you to really
just take our word for it.
We've actually been testing this
with a number of early access
partners, and we really
want to thank them
for all of their hard work in
helping us iterate on this.
We also have a number of topics
that we've touched on, here.
We know that we were
going lightning fast,
so we encourage you to go
see any of our other sister
presentations here at Next.
Or, if you missed
some of those, they
will all be on YouTube later on.
So you can go watch each
one of these presentations
right there, as well.
In closing, the AI Hub is now
open as a beta product for you
to use.
Anybody with a Google account
can use any of the assets
there.
And if you've got
a G Suites account,
you can easily share that
within your organization.
And we'll be rolling
out access controls
to make that much more widely
available as we see fit,
or as you see fit.
We want to partner with you.
We want your feedback.
This is the beginning
of a joint journey
that we want to do with you, so
we really value your feedback.
There is a Feedback button
on the top right hand
side of the Hub.
We would love for
you to submit what
you like, what you wish we
would add, whatever it is.
That's a very valuable
feedback for us,
and we hope to go on
this journey with you.
If you have content
that you would actually
like to share to the
world and publish
as part of the public hub, we
are completely open to that,
and please contact us.
There's a form at the bottom of
the Hub where you can actually
apply, and then we can start
that conversation with you.
And in closing, we
just want to thank
you very much for
the opportunity
to share this with you, and
we hope to talk to you more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]